oh it is it is a blast rocky in fact i
brought barrett jackson to us right now
check out this
check out this ferrari i have here
actually this ferrari belongs to marcus
and he stopped by to make a donation for
our founders day
marcus this is your company car yes yes
on behalf of lvc exactly we just want to
come donate some water there's a lot of
thirsty people out there
they just want to help out we see y'all
been out here all day all day so we just
wanted to help out a little bit that's
awesome i love that business is coming
together and by the way
you can rent this beautiful car thank
you marcus business is coming to donate
and all the everything we collect goes
to two great causes
we're talking about three square and
also the salvation army and this is juan
with the salvation army one
what does it mean when people like
marcus come down and make a donation you
know it's amazing when people the
community comes together right and gives
it and
it's going to go to a great cause when
we deal with somebody that is homeless
somebody that
you know that needs that help we want to
be that helping hand okay i'm not going
to wrap it up soon but someone's
watching right now
what what can they bring what do we need
down here you know men women's clothing
uh water
it's a necessity especially in this heat
so and that when we deal with the
homeless this is very helpful
that's awesome and we have everyone out
here the the whole eight news now staff
is out here hanging out as well we're
gonna be out here all afternoon this is
it
we got a great thing going and we make
it very easy marcus just pulled up
we took the water out we put it in the
boxes we're good to go thank you again
marcus
juan you stick around we have more
questions for you later on so uh rocky
we're doing well out here
things are things are moving along we're
getting some donations it's not a bad
afternoon
got some stuff in here as well i love it
i was loving how everybody can just stay
in their air-conditioned car we make it
so easy for everybody
yeah you know we're out here until six
o'clock so if you're if you're watching
right now and you're getting off work
you still have time to come down here
and six o'clock we'll take all your
stuff and
i'll be out here until five and rocky's
gonna come join me so come here go make
a donation you guys
have a great day